Yo soy yo soy alguien alguien lo
imposible porque entremos a la
universidad lo único que me importa
es ganar yo soy yo soy alguien alguien
[Música]
reunimos a seis personas birraciales soy
birracial soy birracial soy birracial
soy birracial
uno de ellos es blanco si el grupo
descubre el impostor ganará el premio en
efectivo
pero si no lo hacen el impostor se
llevará todo el premio Quién es el
impostor
empezamos diciendo nuestras razas Sí me
parece una buena idea en mi caso mi mamá
es India y mi papá es blanco soy blindio
yo soy Mitad taiwanés y Mitad blanco sí
yo soy coreana y blanca de acuerdo soy
un cuarto negra y mi mamá es blanca
yo soy mitad negra y Mitad francesa o
blanca
sospeché un poco de daria y ella siento
que su cabello era solo una distracción
o una trampa soy nativa estadounidense y
mexicana cómo se conocieron sus padres
los míos se conocieron en el cine mi
mamá trabajaba ahí y mi papá la vio y se
enamoró de ella así que iba siempre a
ver películas para verla
son adorable mi padre daba clases de
tenis en la universidad de Missouri y mi
madre era un estudiante internacional
que se escribió en sus clases mediante
internacional Eso suena
dijo Oh era estudiante internacional y
sentí que me estaba atacando por eso
pensé mmm podría ser ella los míos
estudiaron juntos en la universidad Mi
padre es de Georgia y mi madre vino de
Francia para estudiar en Estados Unidos
se conocieron caminando en la Facultad
de ingeniería mis padres se conocieron
en una barbacoa mi padre era militar y
estaba en una misión en Corea del Sur y
mi mamá lo conoció en una barbacoa de un
amigo me dijo que pensaba que los
estadounidenses eran muy raros porque mi
padre llegó en shorts sandalias una
camisa de botones y un gorro ruso
durante el invierno
y él le dijo nos casamos y ella le dijo
Sí claro mis padres se conocieron en Los
Ángeles porque vivían aquí no fue nada
del otro mundo
dijo que se conocieron en Los Ángeles
pero no dio más detalles todos contamos
más cosas de nuestros padres así que me
pareció raro tanto mi madre como mi
padre son de Arizona
ellos se conocieron
en un bar
Sí mi mamá forma parte de la tribu
navajo
eso fue rápido
[Música]
note que estaba muy nerviosa y nos dio
muchos detalles
en pocas palabras
Ela se ve más blanca Aunque eso no
significa nada
tenemos un empate de tres enseño
entre Ela caitlyn Italia cada una tendrá
30 segundos para defenderse a mi cabello
natural es un afro lo tengo trenzado y
con extensiones porque es más fácil pero
tengo rizos 4b mi padre tiene el cabello
igual que yo el resto es blanco porque
mi padre es mitad belga y Mitad negro y
mi madre es blanca Lamentablemente soy
demasiado pálida y ni siquiera me
bronceo la única prueba es mi cabello Mi
madre es francesa nació y creció allá y
mi padre creció en Estados Unidos en
Georgia crecía en Arizona como tú porque
mis padres se mudaron y nos tuvieron a
mí y a mis hermanos mi hermana y yo
somos las más pálidas mi hermano
si parece negro la verdad es que somos
muy diferentes
estaba diciendo que mi madre forma parte
de la tribu na bajo y Mi padre es
mexicano pero creció en Arizona entonces
tengo partes iguales de
cada uno de ellos Supongo sí sí
empezó a reírse mucho mientras contaba a
su historia y pensé mmm hay algo
sospechoso
sé que lo hicieron Porque parezco más
blanca levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue con ustedes y quieren
seguir jugando
tengo una pregunta porque dijiste que
eres guapa no es decir que eres un
cuarto de una raza Oh así se dice
Gracias tengo un amigo que también es
guapa Cómo te sentías al principio
porque como una persona birracial a
veces te sientes como un impostor en tu
propia cultura sí me ha pasado Soy la
más blanca de todos mis hermanos mi
hermana tiene el color de piel de
Rihanna y mi hermano se ve muy bronceado
y luego estoy yo chica blanca con un
afro enorme
todos me preguntan por qué mi cabello es
así y debo explicarles que es un afro
explicarle a la gente quién soy es
difícil a veces pero me enorgullece
decir que soy en parte negra y que por
eso mi cabello es así aunque me tomó
tiempo amarme como soy ustedes se han
sentido Si antes todas las veces que he
ido de visita a la India suele pasarme
que soy la persona más Blanca en una
habitación y eso me hace sentir que no
soy indio dijo que había ido a la India
y se sintió muy forzado luego no dijo
nada más y dejó de dar detalles sobre la
historia para mí que soy de Colorado
suele pasarme que allá soy muy asiático
para ser blanco pero ahora que estudió
en California donde hay más diversidad
siento que soy muy blanco para ser
asiático así que sin importar que hagas
siento algún tipo de exclusión y siento
que eso es uno de los problemas que
enfrentamos las personas birraciales
cuando era más pequeña me veía más
ambigua la gente decía que era un
Camaleón porque a medida que crecía me
veía más diferente casi siempre se
burlaban de mí en especial estudiantes
coreanos a quienes no les agradan las
personas birraciales
pensaban que personas como yo no
deberían existir y cosas así
sigo aquí
crecí en vecindarios blancos toda mi
vida
y no habló el idioma tampoco hablo
navajo nunca tuve 15 años nunca vivía al
100% cada cultura claro para mí que
crecí con la familia de mi madre que es
blanca porque la familia de mi padre
vivía muy lejos perdí la experiencia de
probar mucha comida negra la descubrí
cuando estaba más grande me hubiese
gustado disfrutarla más al menos todos
Hablamos
su historia no fue nada consistente fue
detallada en unas partes y en otras no
dijo casi nada
[Música]
vaya no quería perder Pero está bien
levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue adentro y quieren
continuar con el juego Creo que cuando
eliminemos a the van ganaremos si lo
haremos si se encienden las luces verdes
significa que eliminaron al impostor y
ganaron sin embargo si se encienden las
luces rojas significa que el impostor
sigue en la caja y perdieron
[Risas]
dinero para la gasolina
que el impostor de Un paso adelante
en tres
dos uno
soy libanesa soy de medio oriente
técnicamente Blanca en Estados Unidos
las personas de Egipto tunisia Argelia y
medio oriente son consideradas blancas
en Estados Unidos es una muestra de lo
arbitrario que es el término blanco y
cómo se les aplica a las personas
siempre me ha parecido tonto que solo
puede ser blanco negro asiático las
categorías son tan limitadas cuando hago
un censo digo que soy Blanca Porque
parezco ser blanca esto es una
demostración de que no importa cómo se
ve a alguien puede servirracial como tú
por tu cabello al principio todos
pensamos que podría servir racial por
tus rizos sí
gracias
[Risas]